le groupe constructive pourrait mettre
également au sénat est ce que ça peut
faire exploser le groupe ait l'air ici
non je ne le crois pas et je le dis mais
papa avec bonheur et joie
moi j'ai passé j'ai passé l'âge et des
petites phrases et des arrière pensées
des petits calculs de carrière et pour
un certain nombre de cas franchement ça
m'inspire pas beaucoup d'indulgence mais
s'il y en a qui sont sincèrement
considère que ce que fait le président
de la république ce que fait la majorité
est formidable c'est assez logique mais
qu'ils aillent au bout de leur logique
qui les rejoignent équité et manuel r
mais écoutez quand tu vois je peux
redire personnes ont été investis
soutenu est finalement élu grâce à
l'étiquette des républicains et puis le
lendemain ils s'en vont franchement est
ce qu'on ne peut être épaté sur le point
sur le plan moral je suis là et pas
quelle sanction pr et moi je pense
qu'ils doivent partir voilà repartir
clairement mais c'est à partir parce que
durant les jeux leur bonne foi je vends
ta mais les procédures je vous le dis
vraiment du très profondément
cela serait respectable et morale les
deux voilà ils ont ils nous ont quittés
ils sont partis ils ont certains pour
certains étaient récompensés puisqu'ils
sont au gouvernement mais je pense que
ça serait plus morale et respectable
qu'ils en tirent toutes les toutes les
conclusions